this is a second thought video in
collaboration with Kento bento make sure
to check out their video after this for
years society has been obsessed with the
idea of some far-off point when the
future begins usually involving flying
cars or spaceships or super intelligent
robots regardless of when we think this
bright and shiny future will arrive in
all its glory it's exciting to try to
predict upcoming events especially those
within our lifetime but there are so
many possible future events around the
world that we'd never be able to cover
the most interesting ones so without
further ado let's take a look at a few
of the projected events in North America
by the middle of the century just around
the corner in early to mid 2019 we'll
get to witness one of the most highly
anticipated space launches in recent
memory the James Webb Space Telescope
originally slated for launch in October
of 2018 will finally begin its
operations in space giving us new
insights into the early universe capable
of seeing the very first generation of
stars that form just 200 million years
after the Big Bang Webb's four main
objectives are to study the formation
and evolution of galaxies search for
light from the first stars and galaxies
that formed after the Big Bang
understand the formation of stars and
planetary systems and to study these
planetary systems and the origins of
life the launch of the James Webb Space
Telescope will mark the beginning of a
very exciting time for space exploration
in 2020 we'll see the first test flights
of NASA's quiet supersonic technology
their new low boom supersonic passenger
planes will be a departure from
traditional tube and wing airplane
construction and are intended to make
air travel greener safer and quieter
reducing fossil fuel use emissions and
noise the new technologies employed by
these planes will lead to a savings of
approximately 255 billion dollars
between 2025 and 2050 also in 2020
Glacier National Park in Montana will
have become completely ice-free the
parks namesake having disappeared as a
result of global warming and earlier
prediction for this event put the
estimate at 2030 but more recent data
gathered in 2009 has indicated a
temperature increase more than twice as
rapid as previously thought many cold
water dependent plants and animals will
die off including a number of rare
species the lack of spring melt will
decrease the overall water level in the
area and lead to more frequent and
severe wildfires finally 2020 we'll also
see a drastically increased number of
drone
patrolling the skies of the United
States in 2012 there were about 7,000
drones used mainly for counter-narcotics
applications and public relief efforts
by 2020 we'll see a fleet of official
drone sporting advanced monitoring
equipment including infrared cameras and
radar and some models will even be
equipped with tasers and rubber bullets
in some cities these drones will be used
to monitor protests and spy on citizens
with no warrant or legal process
needless to say these plans have raised
some very serious privacy and civil
liberty concerns in 2023 NASA will
launch the first manned test flight of
its Orion spacecraft the vessel that
will eventually take humans to Mars four
astronauts will be carried to a distant
orbit about 71 thousand kilometres from
the moon for about two weeks this
mission will be the first time humans
have left low-earth orbit since Apollo
17 in December of 1972 more than 50
years earlier on April 8th 2024 North
America will experience a total solar
eclipse it will be the first total solar
eclipse visible from the US since 2017
the first visible from Mexico since 1991
and the first visible from Canada since
1979 it will be the only total solar
eclipse of the 21st century where
totality is visible from all three
countries in 2025 will potentially see
another amazing spacecraft make its
debut the advanced technology large
aperture Space Telescope or at last will
dwarf not only Hubble but also the James
Webb Space Telescope with a 16 metre
primary mirror versus 6.5 meters on Webb
at last will be designed to search for
life in the galaxy detecting bio
signatures such as oxygen and water the
craft will have such a powerful
resolution that it'll be able to detect
the composition of atmospheres and the
ground conditions of exoplanets up to a
hundred and fifty light years away by
2028 scientists expect to have brought
several extinct species back to life
back in 2009 the first successful
de-extinction lasted just seven minutes
after a Pyrenean ibex was born and
quickly succumbed to lung defects the
species most likely to be brought back
include the wild pigeon and the dodo by
the end of the 2020s any hope of
recovering the titanic will have faded
decades under the water and exposure to
metal eating bacteria will have reduced
the once-mighty vessel to an
insignificant rust
however some artifacts on board may
remain in a recoverable State by the
beginning of the 2030s many experts
expect the United States to be declining
as a world power growing national debt
drastically reduced manufacturing and an
over stretched military are expected to
weaken the US economy significantly
allowing other nations a chance to grab
some of the global spotlight we may see
Shanghai eclipse Wall Street as the
leading financial center and China and
India are expected to make a huge impact
on the world stage the US will maintain
its superpower status but will probably
be less of the behemoth it once was by
the latter half of the 2030s we could
likely see permanent manned bases on the
moon made possible partly by the
development of new heavy-lift rockets
it's expected that NASA other foreign
space agencies as well as private
organizations will be researching and
constructing human habitats both
independently and in cooperation with
foreign and domestic partners by 2037
the number of bombers in the US Air
Force will have fallen below the
required 170 aircraft due to a number of
reasons including the decommissioning of
the last b-52s currently given the
clever codename 2037 bomber this new
generation stealth bomber will
supposedly be the most advanced aircraft
ever created equipped with unparalleled
stealth technology a range that enables
it to strike targets almost anywhere in
the world a payload which includes
nuclear capability and the option to be
piloted remotely or even completely
autonomously during the early 2040 we'll
likely see a submarine mission to
Saturn's moon Titan NASA will deliver an
unmanned submarine probe to one of the
huge methane lakes on Titan and the
craft will gather critical data and
high-definition video of the strange
subsurface world this environment
couldn't support life as we know it on
earth but that doesn't mean we won't
discover something a little more alien
also during the early to mid 20 40 s
we'll probably see the last World War
two veterans pass away marking the end
of first-hand accounts of what will
probably be the last global scale war
some of these veterans may live to see
the hundredth anniversary commemoration
of d-day On June 6 2014 the state a time
capsule will be opened close to Normandy
which contains newspaper articles and
letters from the time including a
message from President Eisenhower to
future generations by the end of the
2040s many Gulf Coast cities will have
to be abandoned due to the
ongoing threat of super hurricanes
climate change will have sparked the
emergence of these unbelievably powerful
storms leading to the temporary and
sometimes permanent evacuation of
coastal cities 200 mile per hour winds
flash floods and waves dozens of meters
high overwhelm cities like Houston and
New Orleans causing untold devastation
and finally by 2050 we should see a
world more connected than ever before
at this point practically all major
continents with the exception of poor
lonely Australia will be connected to
each other by highway rail or tunnel
interestingly the pan-american highway
was just barely disconnected until this
point the massive highway that stretches
all the way from Prudhoe Bay in Alaska
down to via Argentina is only broken by
a 106 kilometers called the Darien Gap a
giant stretch of untamed swamp and
forest impossible to cross by
conventional motor vehicle once a road
across the Darien Gap can be established
the world will essentially be completely
connected by ground-based transportation
if you're interested to learn more about
the trans global highways that relates
to Asia and some of the exciting
upcoming events in that region of the
world make sure to watch this video by
Kento bento next these are just a small
selection of the likely events leading
up to the middle of the century and who
knows what other surprises we have in
store the future might not be all flying
cars and robots but we certainly have
some exciting and terrifying things to
look forward to thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week